[Music]
trade ahead online crime daily
witness testimony begins in the alex
jones defamation trial out of
connecticut is what you saw in that
school fake
no no
no sir was it synthetic oh sir
see any actors that day bill
and the pike county massacre why some
witness testimony will not be broadcast
plus a verdict may soon be handed down
in the federal sex crimes trial of
singer r kelly and later a bombshell
from the parkland school shooters
defense team at this time the defense
rests
we're not playing chess i mean
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host brian buckmaier testimony
kicks off with an emotional witness in
the alex jones defamation trial out of
connecticut
last month the texas jury ordered jones
to pay 49.3 million dollars in damages
to the parents of jesse lewis a student
who was shot and killed in the 2012
massacre jones now faces trial in
connecticut where 15 plaintiffs filed a
total of three lawsuits against him
after he claimed that the school
shooting was a hoax put on by crisis
actors the plaintiffs made up of family
members of the students killed and an
fbi agent say jones followers have
harassed them and even made death
threats jones has already been found
liable for damages in the case meaning
jurors will now decide how much jones
should pay an ex-fbi agent william
aldenberg was the first witness called
in the case he broke down several times
throughout his testimony recalling the
day of the shooting in 2014 and the
harassment from jones's followers
it's one of the worst things that ever
happened if not the worst thing that
ever happened here
right
what happened to them
and
it
and people want to say the student
didn't happen
and and then they want to get rich off
of it
that's the worst part like you know what
you could say whatever you want about me
i don't care if you just say whatever
you want i'm freaking a big boy i can
take it
then they want they want to make profits
they want to make millions and millions
of dollars they want to destroy people's
lives
their children got
slaughtered i saw it myself
and now they have to listen sit here
listen to me say this
and
these people made millions upon millions
upon millions they destroyed everybody
they don't give a damn
that's why that's what's up study above
testimony continued on wednesday as an
attorney for jones's company free speech
systems took the stand attorneys grilled
her on jones's claim of telling the
truth to a loyal following
free speech systems agrees that alex
jones has built a very loyal focus
correct sure okay a very engaged model
yes yes his credibility
with his audience is central to his
ability to sell their products correct
i think he said that too so yes
and that's why he tells them that when
they come to infowars he'll give them
the truth and nothing but right
i think that's one of his
taglines so yes and he tells he calls
his audience truth seekers correct yes
and even though alex jones is not a
journalist
he tells his audience that he will
deliver them the truth in journalism
correct
i think that's also a tagline yes
joining us today is legal analyst
florina altschiller and co-host terry
austin playing an ex-fbi agent
oldenburg's testimony there as you saw
where he broke down on the stand seems
to resonate with law and crime viewers
do you think it's doing the same with
the jury
uh you know we can't see the jury's
reaction but i can't imagine how this
sincere
emotional and impactful testimony is not
resonating with the jury this is a man
who walked into an elementary school
first on scene to discover 20 dead
children
not actors and actresses
20
dead
children of course he's going to have an
emotional reaction and of course he's
going to relive that moment now
emotionally on the witness stand and i
expect that it's going to have a very
powerful effect on the jury that's going
to result in a significant monetary
damage award i think the same as well
terry the judge does not seem to be very
impressed with the defense could jones
attorney be doing more harm than good
absolutely you know his attorney managed
to antagonize judge bellas which doesn't
bode well for alex jones norman pattis
is his attorney and he's normally quite
flamboyant he's ostentatious he has
represented some very major clients
photos dulos before he passed away but
his arguments have not been based on the
law during his opening statement he was
rambling it didn't really make sense and
it also hasn't been based on facts and
in fact the judge made him stop talking
about certain things that aren't going
to come into the case for instance he
repeatedly made references to hillary
clinton and the 2016 election so he's
kind of going off base here and it's not
helping his client yeah the judge even
commented on that doesn't want to hear
no more about hillary clinton in the
courts it's uh maybe not the best tactic
to pull in court but we'll see how it
continues and in california the trial of
paul and reuben flores is off for the
rest of the week after just one day of
testimony as the father and son face
charges in the 1996 disappearance and
death of kristin smart the cal poly
student went missing after a party in
may of 1996 but the case went cold for
two decades with very few leads paul and
ruben flores were long suspected in the
case and were arrested just last year
witnesses say paul was the last person
seen was smart he is charged with her
murder reuben is charged with accessory
after the fact for allegedly helping to
hide the body accused of burying her in
his backyard and later moving her
smart's body has never been found the
only day of testimony this week included
a woman who said paul told her he had
buried smart under the ramp at his home
the summer after she went missing she
said she was a teenager at the time and
was scared to tell anyone about the
conversation jennifer hudson broke down
in tears several times while on the
stand telling jurors she felt partially
responsible for the smart family
suffering all these years testimony is
set to resume next monday
still ahead on law and crime daily a
verdict may soon be handed down to
disgrace r b singer r kelly but first
the pike county massacre what witnesses
the prosecution calls to testify as
george wagner iv is tried for murder
[Music]
welcome back the jury hears from several
law enforcement officers who opted not
to be broadcast on tv in the pike county
massacre trial of defending george
wagner iv wagner his brother jacob and
their parents are charged with murdering
eight members of the rhoden and gilly
families in april of 2016. prosecutors
say the shooting deaths came amid a
custody dispute involving a young child
jacob wagner shared with hannah rhoden
the victims were found shot to death in
their homes in four different locations
most were shot as they slept jake has
already pled guilty to the murders and
will spend the rest of his life in
prison and has agreed to testify against
his family members george wagner iv says
he's not guilty because he didn't
actually pull the trigger in the crimes
the case is considered one of ohio's
largest criminal investigations
wednesday several witnesses opted not to
be on camera including pike county
sheriff tracy evans who is an elected
official another pike county deputy
testified on camera about one of the
crime scenes and finding several of the
victims dead with her baby still alive
beside them
terry how much of the case rests on jake
and angela's testimony and do you think
the jury will find accomplices of such a
murder credible
you know anytime you have an accomplice
and they're testifying that jury is
going to pay very close attention they
want to figure out whether or not the
person testifying is telling the truth
or whether they're going to point the
finger to someone else and in this case
you have two family members so the
jury's going to pay even closer
attention one of the things that jake is
going to testify is the fact that
everyone was involved and he has already
admitted to carrying out five of the
murders but in exchange as you said for
his testimony he's not going to get the
death penalty and the others are not
going to get the death penalty and
they're going to listen to angela as
well you know it must be hard for a
mother to be testifying against a son
and against a you know her husband
frankly i think the jury is definitely
going to want to see what she has to say
and they're going to think she's telling
the truth because why would anyone say
anything negative against your family
member absolutely serena i get it the
average person the the doctor the
teacher the small business owner they
may want to opt out of being able to be
shown on camera but
do you think police officers should have
that ability as well
absolutely not you know i absolutely
understand and respect that people who
are witnesses or victims of a crime may
want their privacy and may not want this
horrible tragedy to be televised for the
world to see as entertainment
however when it comes to police officers
their job is to investigate crime and
testify at trial that is their job i
don't think they should have the
privilege of choosing whether or not
their testimony gets televised because
it's completely part of what they're
being paid to do and so to opt out of it
is just like a firefighter saying i'll
run into a burning building oh but not
if it's a four-alarm fire not gonna run
into that one they shouldn't have that
choice yeah i also don't see the harms
that they would face like a like a
regular citizen but that's what's
happening in that case well switching to
tennessee the man accused of going on a
shooting rampage through memphis last
week appears before a judge as a gag
order is put in place in the case of
ezekiel kelly kelly allegedly shot six
people last wednesday three of them
fatally police initially thought there
was a fourth victim but later determined
that one was not connected officials say
kelly live streamed one of the shootings
on social media after which a manhunt
began police believe all but one of the
shootings were random after his arrest
the 19 year-old was arraigned on one
charge of first-degree murder and is
being held without bond he appeared on
tuesday morning before the judge for
only a brief five minutes during which
the judge ordered the case not be
discussed publicly and told kelly to
return to court on friday the 19 year
old has been out of jail less than five
months at the time of the shooting after
11 months in jail for a 2020 aggravated
assault
coming up on law and crime daily the
defense makes a startling announcement
in the parkland school shooter penalty
phase trial plus the jury moves into
deliberations as r kelly stands trial on
federal sex crimes
[Music]
welcome back an illinois jury hands down
a verdict as disgrace r b singer r kelly
stands trial on federal sex crimes
allegations of kelly's misconduct dates
back to the early 1990s kellyanne's
co-defendant and former business manager
daryl mcdavid are charged with fixing
kelly's child pornography trial in 2008
in which kelly was acquitted
he allegedly threatened witnesses and
concealed video evidence including an
alleged sex tape with a then 14 year old
girl who did not testify in 2008 but
took the stand in this trial admitting
she was the one in the video she told
the jury r kelly sexually abused her
over a hundred times closing arguments
were presented all day monday and into
tuesday as prosecutors called for
justice for the women abused by kelly
for his team's defense attorneys slammed
government witnesses saying they were
liars who only testified under immunity
during closings a juror suffered a panic
attack a panic attack saying she
couldn't handle one minute more she was
later dismissed on wednesday jurors
brought forward three questions asking
for records and clarification on the
wording of kelly's charges in june kelly
was sentenced to 30 years in prison for
separate federal sex crimes convictions
terry a few questions asked by the jury
what issue do you think would have taken
them the longest to decide
well it's interesting it didn't take
them long at all we don't know what the
verdict is but i think one of the issues
they may have been having trouble with
was whether or not there was obstruction
as far as kelly's concern on that 2008
trial that was a long time ago the
evidence might not have been as fresh as
some of the new evidence but i do think
if they found him guilty on one count he
will probably be found guilty
on most of the other counts as far as
the co-defendant mcdavid is concerned
he's the former manager i think he may
not have gotten a conviction on all
counts but we will see
all in all there were 13 counts
everything ranging from child
pornography to obstruction of justice to
receiving child pornography and enticing
minors for sex so we'll see how the
judge and the jury come out on this but
i think they took it very seriously and
looked at all of that evidence florina i
know it's innocent until proven guilty
but i think
the assumption is he might be found
guilty how does this work out with his
last conviction in new york and how's
that jail time going to play out
the judge is going to be bound by the
sentencing guidelines but i think it's
fair to say he's 55 years old he's
already serving a sentence of 30 years
this other sentence if convicted is
going to run consecutively
not concurrent because this is a
completely separate case separate trial
there's separate instances so there's no
way to stack it so he's not going to get
out until really he's dead i i'm
expecting that the sentencing guidelines
are going to look at the prior
conviction as an aggravating factor and
he's going to be handed down a sentence
of several decades all right we'll see
how that verdict comes in also in
celebrity news a new york photographer
is suing pop singer miley cyrus after
she posted a photo he took of her on her
social media the photographer claims
cyrus posted the image without his
permission which he says violates his
copyright holding the filing is among 20
copyright lawsuits by robert barbera he
has brought against celebrities and
business businesses over the last three
years including justin bieber ariana
grande and dua lipa according to the
lawsuit barbara had taken the photo of
cyrus waving as she exited a building in
february of 2020. she posted the photo
online that same day barbara registered
the image with the u.s copyright office
in april but didn't realize cyrus had
posted it to instagram until a month
later he claims the photo increased
traffic to the singer's account and gave
her an increase in revenues many of his
cases have been settled within a couple
months of being filed there's no word on
how much money barbera is seeking
when we come back we look to florida for
the parkland school shooter penalty
phase trial that's where a shocking move
by the defense leaves the judge the
case's judge in shock and off
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily an
elected nevada official makes his first
court appearance after his arrest for
the murder of a prominent las vegas
journalist 44 year old robert tells made
his first court appearance on tuesday
just weeks after renowned investigative
journalist jeff german was found stabbed
to death outside of his home german had
previously reported on tells workplace
misconduct for the las vegas review
journal tells was charged with
premeditated murder as prosecutors
allege he was lying in wait for the
reporter before he killed him he's due
back in court on september 20th to be
arraigned
headed east to florida where the
parkland school shooter penalty phase
trial takes a shocking turn when the
defense rests its case and the presiding
judge calls the move uncalled for and
unprofessional
in the weeks-long trial a broward county
jury will decide whether the parkland
school shooter will receive life in
prison or the death penalty last year he
pled guilty to all charges stemming from
the 2018 school shooting where 17 people
were killed and 17 more injured while
the trial began in mid-july the defense
began its case only three weeks ago
calling witnesses that spoke of the
defendant's difficult upbringing court
resumed wednesday morning where the
defense was expected to continue its
case that included 800 potential
witnesses after refusing to tell the
judge who was the next witness and
attorney questioning them the defense
abruptly rested his case
yes at this time the defense rests
other than putting in our records
we're not playing chess i mean
will you please take the jewelry back in
thank you all right go ahead and put in
your records
to be
nicholas cruz henderson said one referee
balloon is
are you going to have anything ready for
today
no
we're waiting for 40 more witnesses i
just want to say this is the most
uncalled for
unprofessional way to try a case
you you all knew about this and even if
you didn't make your decision until this
morning to have 22 people plus all of
this staff and every attorney march into
court be waiting as if it's some kind of
game
now i have to send them home the state's
not ready they're not going to have a
witness ready we have another day wasted
i i just i honestly i have never
experienced a level of unprofessionalism
in my career it's unbelievable
the prosecution indicated it was not
prepared for a rebuttal case on
wednesday judge freer then dismissed the
jury until september 27th
florida the defense has rested its case
in what seems like an unprofessional way
according to the judge but where do you
see the strengths in their case
unfortunately
since the defendant pled guilty and
there's no question that he did this and
this is the most horrific crime i could
possibly think of can it killing
innocent school children the question
before this jury is whether or not to
execute him what the defense did well is
they put on evidence of fetal alcohol
syndrome and of how nicholas cruz was
essentially assaulted starting as a
fetus in a womb
and how his brain resultantly was not
able to develop properly
the problem is
he killed a lot of innocent school
children and i think that even if true
even if he had fetal alcohol syndrome
that is an excuse that's not going to
excuse away the death penalty penalty
for a crime that is the most horrific
crime that a person can possibly commit
and there's no question here that he's
the one that committed it he's already
pled guilty to all of the counts
absolutely terry so where does the
prosecution go with a rebuttal
you know they only have two weeks which
actually is an unusually amount of time
for this type of you know case for a
rebuttal where we're only focusing on
the life or the death issue but i do
think they're going to look at those
aggravating factors particularly that it
was heinous and that it was premeditated
absolutely we'll see how it plays out
well thank you for joining us here on
law and crime daily we'll see you next
time as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you